i have a couple things a couple opinions
to about um
about
jake paul and who he should fight and i
have some opinions about who he should
not fight okay
i don't want him to fight
i don't want him to fight certain guys i
don't i do
tell me tell me who you want before you
go down the rabbit hole
saying who you don't want fights easy
yeah
who do you who would you like him to
fight
i'd like to i'd like him to fight nate
diaz
not nick diaz
and i think if he fights nick diaz and
he especially if he fights jorge
masvidal very bad idea
see jorge is a better fight from the
nick or nate diaz oh no no i oh no look
at what jorge did to nate you're talking
about mma oh wait what nick are you
talking about you said nate i'm talking
about nate diaz the idea is i think is
he he has an easier time with nate
um because i don't know that nate hits
as hard it's but it doesn't matter it's
nate's pressure they think how tired he
was against woodley and woodley
really didn't throw they don't get tired
eight is gonna be in your grill
so if you don't knock him out that first
second round and you go eight rounds one
that fifth six seven eight is going to
be a nightmare this is true and it's
just volume
volume like how many punches they threw
yeah it's gonna be quadruple that with
nate yeah and nate nate um although
and nate's nate's forte i mean he's
obviously jiu jitsu he's uh great off
his back but he box box and sustain yeah
the only thing is i would say is that
that i i am really impressed with how
hard
jake hits so i i don't know that if nate
is in this grill like that i don't know
if anybody's head can take that kind of
pressure so i've been knocked out once
yeah um i i so nick
i think nate's a better fight i think
nick is real trouble and i think i think
jorge is real trouble i think i think a
guy i think he has to stay away from
guys like kevin gaslam
guys like even even the guy who beat
this is stupid
those ufc fights bad ideas tell me who
you want to fight because all those are
unrealistic because they're under ufc
contract
so dana's gonna have to play ball with
showtime and they hate each other okay
it could like a connor could happen
because it's such a big payday and dana
likes money so does espinoza so that
could possibly happen down the road but
unless it's a massive massive payday
data is connor too small for him
better boxer but
yeah he's too small yeah but
i don't want to see i don't want to see
somebody who's
i don't want to see somebody
i'm caught i'm torn because i love this
kid and i don't want to see him get beat
up by somebody who's really good i'm not
interested in that i love his gun
boxing for three years dude but that's
why you should stick with these mma guys
correct
i don't want to see him fight some
he could fight him
he'd beat the shadow i would love to see
he would after watching last night he'd
be done
um so who give me you haven't given me
one legit matchup
because i can't think of anybody that
anderson silva
anderson self would be a good matchup
and i think anderson will probably beat
him
right you would think i think so let's
just see what i did julio chavez yeah
junior i mean that's a big deal on
anderson let's see how he looks anderson
now
40 something six
yeah probably 46 47 maybe even older and
then
damn i'm good i would love to see that
that's the fight i'd like to see uh the
smart next step like you're fighting an
actual like striking expert instead of
just these wrestlers who also fight
correct that would be that would be
that's idea like you'd be um is nick
diaz too much for him
see if you care about them i don't like
those diaz brothers
they can box dude and i do care about
them they can box yes
that's the thing i don't want to see
this kid
take a whole bunch of head trauma i love
what he's doing for the sport and he's
fun and i love these challenges would
you watch would you buy another woodley
rematch i would i don't well i don't
care i would but i'm i don't care i
think we'd see it again i think we might
see this maybe the same result i think
that time is on jake's side and time is
not on tyrant's side yeah i think for
jake they can't probably just need to
move on from that like all right you did
that now now let's fight for the next
like a real strike you won that fight oh
yeah and square yeah i give woodley and
you know i'm on i'm
biased towards woodley i had three
rounds okay me too i would too but real
estate probably won two right
so i'm i'm i'm done with that
um but yeah but there's besides
that and then there's tommy fury there's
a woodley rematch
any of these ufc names you guys
mentioned you got to realize the ufc
would have to be in on the deal and
that's such a nice yeah
is there anybody who's
a retired boxer who's now 50
collecting see i don't know if you can i
don't know if you can still keep doing
that either yeah like fighting older
guys like people are making fun of them
yeah it gets boring like woodley makes
sense you're just retired you know he's
taking all this seriously for sure man
40 is what 43 i think it's like no 30 39
right yeah
i thought woodley uh you just like you
know these people out there like oh was
fakes
he had him rocked ain't going for the
kill then you don't know what you're
talking about if you've ever seen
woodley ever ever fight especially his
last five fights he's just fight senate
he just doesn't pull the trigger that's
just his style yeah
yeah so i i don't know what they do with
jake if he wants to like wait wait it
out and wait for someone to come about
he could do that or there's the woodley
rematch or uh the easy paydays tommy
fury
well yeah
and or or he
does one more fight and moves on
no moves on the way too much money he
probably made 20 mil last night a lot of
money
and he really didn't take too much
damage no how much damage did it take in
practice though how much that's the
price maybe is this the price is it
worth the thing to play 15 million to
fight
i guess it is and he's starting and he's
24 yeah
his sparring partners don't really throw
i saw like a couple videos his that they
do bubba he didn't get ready by should
he sway he trains with world champion
yeah look at the i just i know i don't
care what you see on social media i'm
telling you i know from his team yes he
goes with world champion you're not
getting good like that you want to get
good this fast in three years if he's
fighting [ __ ] he's taking it he's taking
shots like the video like have you seen
the videos him like beating up someone's
smart partner he's like starching him
yep that's just for the grim yeah i i
heard he gets [ __ ] up in practice he's
fighting real dudes yeah he you couldn't
get that good this fast with fighting
bumps correct
his team's pushing him in there they
have to be
and i just don't know what he
i wouldn't like we talked about last
night like what's his ceiling you know
like i'm so curious like i think he he's
his last fights against his brother they
make all the money in the world and then
move on to whatever the [ __ ] they want
to do is his brother training as hard as
he is oh yeah logan yeah you saw him
against floyd yeah yeah
is he got another fight coming up no no
rumors was a logan vs anderson but i
think jake's the one the guy's gonna go
after yeah